みなさん、こんにちは。dogginphoneticsによる日本語音声学の最初のエピソードへようこそ。これ
は、音声
の研究と分類として定義される言語学の分野です。
したがって、日本の音声学
は、簡単に言えば、話し言葉の日本語の研究です。
通常、日本人の学習者は
、日本語の音声学を集中的に研究しません。
通常、基本的な発音のみをカバーし
、
日本語のイントネーションや高低アクセントを勉強することは
ありません。これが、ほとんどの人が最善の
努力と数年の研究にもかかわらず、音声の知識がなく
ても非ネイティブスピーカーでも識別できるほど重い不自然なアクセントに
なることが多い理由です。 たとえば
、日本語のアクセントを確認して改善するために
、すべてのネイティブの日本語話者
は、ラモの
境界線とラモの境界線ラモの
境界線とラモの境界線の違いを知ること
ができます。 なぜなら、彼らは少し発音を勉強している
からです 日本語の方言のアクセントを単独で勉強しないので、
日本語を
学ぶシミールを使いましょう。しかし
、
基本的または基本的な発音で音声学習を停止
することは、ステーキの準備方法を学ぶことと似ています
が、調味料を停止するか
、ステーキの調味料を
基本的な塩に制限します そして、ペッパーシーズニングは、
食用のステーキとおいしいステーキの違いを
生むものです。同様に高度な音声
知識は、
理解しやすい
日本語とネイティブまたはネイティブに近い
日本語の違いを
生むものです。
YouTubeや他の場所で日本語を教える外国人は、
日本語の方言のアクセントやその
教え方
を理解して
いない
ことがよくあります。
このトピック
だけでなく、コモについても包括的に n
日本語の方言のアクセントなどの誤解は
、第3話のアクセントのアクセントであるため、この
シリーズは
、単にカリキュラムを伝えることができるコンテンツ
が
主に
PMsusキー日本語の方言のアクセント日本語の方言
のアクセント
OhJadeIndonesiaや日本語
アクセント辞書第2版のシム、および京方言のアクセントを正式に日本語の方言を集中的に勉強
しているときに得た知識と概念などのリソースを通じて日本語を学んだ私の経験
エピソード2での私の個人的なバックグラウンドの方言のアクセントに加えて、
日本語の方言の
初心者から高度な方までを説明する簡単なビデオカリキュラムに加えて、
いくつかのサードパーティのリソースを提供するつもりです。
必須の日本語の練習などの追加のトピックについて説明します
ghピッチアクセントと
発音の両方を詳細に説明します。レッスンの最初の
バッチでは、日本の学習市場の観察に基づいて
これを行うために選択したピッチアクセントに対処
します。堅実な統合発音リソースを見つけることはそれほど難しくありません
が、同じです。
日本語の高低アクセントについては言えません
高低アクセントのリソース
を十分に活用するには、高度な日本語または言語の知識が必要
になることがよくあります。
その結果、ほとんどの日本人学習者
はある程度発音をカバーし
ますが、最初に高低アクセントを完全にスキップし
ます。 カリキュラムと高低アクセントに関して、現在
ほとんどの学習者の音声の弱点に対処したいと思います。
特に、これらの概念の多くは
理解するのが難しい
場合があります。たとえば
、順序とオーラまたはガルカの違いを聞くことができると
思います。 と悟空は言いますが、あなたは
特定して模倣するのが難しいかもしれません
視覚的なガイドなしで正しいピッチアクセントパターンなので、これらの単語を言うのではなく、
私もこれを行うか、
ディットまたはデットまたはディットまたは
ココのそれは居心地
が良くなりまし
た なじみやすい
ように英語で英語に存在しない
でください。たとえば、これは私が日本のピッチ
アクセントパターンを単語gakusay
から英語の単語辞書にマッピングすることです。
ちなみにこのパターンはTheHavenパターン標準英語辞書として知られています
。
辞書英語ですが
、日本語ならではのちょっと長いパターン
辞書辞書辞書
このパターンを数回使用し
たので、何度か聞いたことがある
ので、もう一度日本語にマッピングしてみましょう。辞書辞書
gaku say aqua say Diagon Pooh  da彼は
うまくいけば、この演習によって
物事が少し簡単になり
ました。おそらく最初にこれを少し行う予定です。
グラフィックスとオーディオキューの両方の組み合わせ
がこれらの概念をより消化しやすくし
ていることを教えてください。このように日本語を話すことを教えられたのはこれが初めてだと思います。
個々の単語を教えることは実際には実用的ではありません。
これは、
一度知ったらやるべきこと
です。これをすぐに行う方法を紹介します。これらのレッスン
では、個々の単語をカバーするのではなく、
高低アクセントを教えます。
この知識を使用
して、頭のてっぺんからわからない単語
の高低アクセントと発音を正確に推測できるような発音パターン。
形容詞の場合
、おそらく過去の発音ではパターンYとパターンZです。
これは、
逆方向に作業して
、学習時間を何時間も節約できるようにするために行うことです。
これらのレッスン
では、すべての種類
の単語
だけでなく、動詞や形容詞の共役形、およびこのシリーズで提示
され
た知識と実践を積極的に研究して適用すると、高低アクセントパターンがカバー
ます。 非常に長い間ネイティブとして識別できたさまざまな高低アクセントパターン
を最終的に識別し、さらに模倣することを可能にした知識
私はそれらをネイティブとして識別できる理由がわかり
ませんでした私はあなたのような方法でほとんどのポイントを紹介
します 理解するために基本的な日本の知識以上のものを持っている必要はありません。
これらの
レッスンは
、音声知識
がすべてのレベルで役立つだけでなく
、カリキュラムのほとんどの情報が
通常は統合されていないか
、英語ですぐに利用できるわけではありませんが、これらの
レッスン全体でこのテレプロンプトを読んでいるのを目にするかもしれません。
私がここにいる
ので、これらのレッスンは
完全にスクリプト化されていますが
、時間制限のために実行されないため
です。この最初のビデオ
に加えて、毎週のYouTubeビデオ
とフルタイムの仕事に加えてこれらのレッスンを行っていることにも注意する必要があります。
このシリーズを急ぐつもりはないので
、隔週でリリースする可能性が高いです。YouTubeでも利用できる
最初の
3つまたは4つのビデオが
、より多くの情報と
理論の基礎として役立つことにも注意してください。 後のレッスン、
言い換えれば、ビデオの最初のバッチは
少し遅いように見えるかもしれませんが、それは意図的
なものがレッスン5からすぐ
に回復して終了します私のYouTube活動をサポートしてくれたすべての人に感謝します
日本の学習コミュニティの何人かのメンバーが私に提案しました
音声学シリーズについての話が出る前にパトレオンページを作る日本の音声学がなる
ことについてのサポートと楽観的なことにとても感謝しています
常連客にとって有用で適切なインセンティブであり、それは
ドーゲンによる日本の音声学への歓迎です。私は
レッスン2をスクリプト化しています。
今後ともよろしくお願い申し上げ
ます。